and let's talk about what is happening
in solidar and why this is so
strategically important to the Russian
event yeah so Jen just talk about the
importance of it first of all if the
Russians take solidar then it puts more
pressure on back mud which they want to
take and it would give them some control
over the supply from slavian's tobacco
you can see the road their backwards
being supplied fairly easily down that
road from slavians if the Russians are
able to take solidar they can interfere
with that with those supplies and it
would mean that the ukrainians would
then have to supply back much further
south through crematorius and so on in
themselves solidar is not a very
important place it's a base of a big
assault mine in Europe backmot is not a
special important place slavigants and
kramatosk are genuinely strategically
important now the Russians say that they
have surrounded solidar they haven't
they're to the North and the South but
they may get us around it they 46 their
mobile Brigade the Ukrainian 46 or very
good they're in solidar at the moment
they won't be rolled over but if they're
about to be surrounded they will have to
withdraw so it's entirely plausible that
the Russians might actually be able to
surround the town but at the moment
they're in three of the four salt mines
they've actually got some stuff
underground they are not in the urban
areas they're at the edge of them and
they're north and south and they've got
The High Ground to the South which is
quite important so I I you know we might
say the Russians are likely to surround
solidar and the 46th mobile may have to
move out but that will resolve itself in
the next few days can we talk weapons
we've heard in recent days about the UK
supplying Ukraine with potentially with
British tanks for the first time that's
not been confirmed by the government yet
no deal has been signed but it is in the
offering what would that mean yeah I
mean this is everybody in the in the
west thinking about the next phase of
the fighting and if the ukrainians are
to continue to be successful they need
heavier weapons and the best tanks in
the world is the American Abrams tank
the leopard two tank the German tank and
the Challenger 2 the British tank and so
the British are saying Challenger twos
they're on the left the British are
saying that maybe they're hinting they
may give 12 one squadron's worth which
actually sitting in Estonia there is a
squadron of Challenger twos in Estonia
they may give 12 tanks to the Ukraine
now 12 tanks even Challenger twos won't
make that much difference what the
ukrainians really want is the leopard
two and the leopard two are operated by
13 different countries in Europe there
are lots of them around lots of spares
lots of ammunition challenges very
specific it's got its own ammunition the
Germans won't give leopard twos because
they fear escalation and so far they
will not license anybody else giving
their leopard twos to Ukraine because
they hold the license to film London
Poland it will probably be resolved at
Ramstein or just around the Ramstein
meeting which is on the 20th of January
week on Friday and this British gesture
it is only a military gesture but it may
it's an attempt I think to release the
uh the long jam and persuade Chantal
Schultz of Germany at least to allow the
licensed countries like Poland and
Finland to give their leopard twos and
ultimately when the ukrainians have got
150 leopard chews then they really would
have the ability to stop in its tracks
the Russian offensive which we know will
come in the spring yeah it's a gesture
but it could be the start of something
as you say particularly if Ukraine have
German tanks in their mind and can we
just talk about what that would mean
in terms of how would that be received
by the Kremlin because at the start of
this war there was a lot of talk about
when Ukraine asked the West for weapons
the West were very clear that they would
only provide defensive weapons because
anything that would put Ukraine at an
advantage on the offense would not be
taken well by the Kremlin and that could
be a massive escalation and Putin has
been very clear about what that would
mean where does this feed into that yeah
it's another escalation I mean we've
been Crossing thresholds from the very
beginning of the war every time we
established a threshold we cross it
because of Russian Behavior Russian war
crimes and the fact that Putin is saying
this war will go on for years I will I
will do whatever it takes I don't care
if I wreck the Russian economy I will
not lose this war and so he's making it
clear that this will just go on so it
poses this existential issue for the
west of security in Europe has changed
fundamentally and for Western Europe and
the United States there is no getting
away from this there's no hiding from it
there's no turning back it is more
dangerous and this year will be a much
more dangerous year than last year but
if we don't do it the point is is that
giving in to Putin appeasing Putin is
more dangerous than opposing Putin and
this is the next threshold we are about
to cross it and after this we'll cross
the threshold I'm sure of giving modern
fighter uh weapons and more modern
aircraft to the ukrainians I mean this
war will get more dangerous yet but we
still got to contain those dangers even
as we embrace them